[Musique]
bah
versant en prêt vous considérez-vous
alain duhamel comme un homme engagé
alors engagée dans mon métier sûrement
oui
engagé politiquement non engagés dans
l'observation politique mais on peut
dire qu'un éditorialiste cette
journaliste engagé on peut dire que pour
est dit pour être éditorialistes il vaut
mieux être engagé à fond dans
journalistes absolument
donc c'est dans le journalisme que vous
êtes engagés pas dans la politique par
l'observation sur les relations de la
politique mais ce que je veux dire c'est
pas engagé partisans n'ont pas partisan
mais engagez vous défendez quelque chose
une idée de plus toutes des idées des
idées et des manières de faire j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion de vous le dire une fois
mais c'est en vous voyant exercer votre
métier que j'ai eu envie de faire le
même c'est étrange ça d'être un modèle
pour qu'elle joue je me considère pas
comme un modèle moi j'étais o'connell je
me considère plutôt comme une anomalie
ah oui oui aussi mon modèle est une
anomalie
non mais ça doit être étrange à vivre
bah oui enfin disons que au début c'est
un peu dérangeant et plus comprendre là
je siffle lui faut relativiser
non parce que j'ai eu à la fois un
itinéraire
oui une méthode de travail et un rôle
qui est assez en fait atypique j'ai
l'air extrêmement raisonnable leur
géologie bien sûr mais c'était atypique
que vous pouvez qualifier cet atypique
non parce que d'abord il ya une part de
hasard très importantes comme tout le
monde dans ce métier et va même de
plusieurs de plusieurs hasard et ensuite
j'ai choisi une voie qui était d'essayer
disons de de m'appuyer sur la culture
politique institutionnelle et historique
pour faire mon métier
deux quotidiens bon c'était un choix oui
c'était pas un choix très fréquent
d'ailleurs ce n'est toujours pas mais
donc je me suis toujours considéré comme
je te réponds au centre mais enfin un
certain à une certaine place et en même
temps à côté
là vous parliez de chance et en même
temps vous venez de vous dire vous avez
un coup de bol
incroyable avec le renouvellement
complète c'est classe politique
avec la disparition des vieux dinosaures
et à droite et à gauche et avec
l'arrivée de tous ces nouveaux c'est un
tram ça vous a remis 100 francs dans la
machine bah en compte en tout cas disons
que c'est ce qu'il pouvait
professionnellement se passer de mieux
jouer ça sert seulement politiquement
mais professionnellement il ya
absolument aucun doute parce que quand
on arrive à un âge canonique
le risque est celui de la répétition et
surtout de tout regarder avec les
lunettes d'avant-hier oui bon et là y'a
pas moyen de faire ça c'est on ne peut
comprendre que si on part du principe
que tout est différent et tout est
différent est ce qu'on va le dire est ce
que ça vous a empêché de vous endormir
le fait qu'ils changent tous pour durer
je suis pas très endormi naturel n'est
pas là mais
j'étais peut-être un risque après tout
j'en sais rien je ne sais pas peut-être
le risque était pour nous tous vous les
aimez les politiques vous aimez la
politique où vous aimez les deux alors
j'aime d'abord la politique parce que
j'aime la démocratie et puis parce que
je m'intéresse à l'évolution de la
société
donc j'aime d'abord la politique ensuite
les politiques il y en a beaucoup pour
qui j'ai eu énormément de considération
voire de sympathie c'est évidemment par
principe général quand vous les aimez
c'est à cause de quoi d'abord c'est
quand je les trouve intelligent et
compétent ça c'est quand même un
préalable
et ensuite quand j'ai l'impression
qu'ils sont vrais je déteste les rôles
de compositrice et sincère c'est la vie
oui oui c'est authentique
ouais j'aime bien les gens authentiques
que j'aime mieux quelqu'un d'
authentiques défendant des idées je
n'aime pas que quelqu'un de non
authentique défendant des idées que je
partage et des gens authentiques vous en
avez croisé beaucoup m'a pas mal oui oui
on va parler de la qualité du personnel
politique puisque vous êtes aux
premières loges
mais avant c'est quand même très
difficile de vous recevoir 100 pour pour
beaucoup beaucoup de gens vous est
indissociable de ça
[Musique]
moi j'en ai plein alors on va le dire et
bien sûr c'est le générique de l'heure
de vérité ce morceau des wings paul
mccartney la composent et qui a décidé
de le choisir ce morceau comme générique
celui qui a vraiment pris la décision je
sais pas si c'est lui qui a eu l'idée
mais celui qui après les divisions
sévérité qui présentait l'émission moi
c'est la seule émission de ma vie
j'aurais fait beaucoup de bruit en deux
types très différents c'est la seule
dont j'ai trouvé l'idée
oui absolument c'est votre idée est en
revanche avec pierre desgraupes on était
tout à fait d'accord pour que je sois
pas le présentateur d'une part pour des
raisons politiques à l'époque parce que
j'avais correspondait pas à l' équilibre
politique du moment du tout et d'autre
part parce que la présentation ne
m'intéresse pas et donc ça faisait déjà
de bonnes raisons et bonne raison
mais les l'idée était de mois et bondi
dans la mécanique mais en revanche
l'habillage les le décor qui était très
beau et très novateur à l'époque le
générique bien sûr mais aussi tous les
détails de mise en scène publique avec
lui les gens qui étaient alors
accueillir à l'entrée le livre
exactement quels souvenirs quel souvenir
vraiment des bons souvenirs pour vous
ces émissions politiques la de cette
émission
d'abord un ici passer beaucoup de choses
oui bon 2 on y a vraiment découvert et
mis à jour toute une génération
politique c'est quand même l'émission
qui a duré le plus de politique qu'a
duré le plus longtemps sans modifier sa
forme et sans modifier ce qui la
présentait un 12 ans donc c'est un pas
assez impressionnant bon et puis il y ai
passé beaucoup de choses ce qui vous a
donné envie ou en tout cas le goût du
politique c'est en 56 la campagne des
législatives je crois on va regarder ça
en france l' approche de la date des
élections commencent à transformer
l'ambiance quotidienne
elle a provoqué sur les trottoirs une
génération spontanée de ces panneaux
désormais classique qui attendent leurs
actifs de toutes les couleurs et de
toutes les nuances politiques
pendant ce temps on imprime des
kilomètres de listes électorales qu'on
songe en effet qu'il ya plus de 5000
candidats pour 537 siège l'année finit
dans la fièvre électorale
qu'on songe en effet que vous venez de
ce monde là alain duhamel c'est fou
c'est loin c'est un autre monde
oui c'est loin puis pour moi c'est à ses
preuves dans ma tête
vous avez quel âge à ce moment là quand
vous voyez ça que vous assistez faisant
seize ans et pierre mendès-france a été
mon premier coup de foudre politique et
à mes grands plaisirs par la suite une
de mes grandes joies même c'est de
l'avoir bien connu
de l'avoir rencontré souvent chez lui
chez moi paris dans le gard aussi on a
chacun une maison etc et on s'est
beaucoup vu on a beaucoup discuté avec
lui en discuter sérieusement j'ai passé
mes 68 avec lui ce qui est une
expérience que je recommande à tout le
monde bien qu'assez peu et des chances
de limiter c'était ou comment chez lui
chez lui c'est lui qui avait envie de il
avait envie de partager mai 68 avec le
regard de trois jeunes à l'époque
j'étais un des trois jeunes est donc on
se voyait ils ont déjeuné chez lui une
fois par semaine puis il téléphonait un
peu entre temps est bon et puis quand je
le voyais en tête à tête
alors là il me faisait lire des grands
auteurs moyens deux hommes qui m'ont
fait l'un des grands auteurs c'est
pierre mendès france est raymond aron se
découvre en vous entendant en fait que
vous êtes un jeune homme qui avait ses
stars il se trouve que ces stars
c'étaient des hommes d'état et que du
coup pour pouvoir les fréquenter vous
vous êtes intéressé vous avez trouvé le
job qui vous permettait de fréquenter
vous star et valence est et vos héros
set ça a été un peu par hasard c'est
d'une certaine manière parce que moi je
me préparais à essayer d'être historia
beau mais l'accès en voiture programme
pendant un an j'ai pas pu faire un bon
bref il n'était plus question que ça et
à ce moment là je me suis tourné vers ce
qui me paraissait le plus proche
c'est à dire le journalisme et la part
coup de chance des choses ont été assez
vite
vous avez été toutes ces années on peut
le dire vous le dirais comme ça aux
premières loges des différents degré
d'engagement
vous le disiez je fais la différence
entre ceux qui sont sincères et ceux qui
ne le sont pas alors bon ça c'est une
manière de qualifier les choses après
celle est sincère il ya aussi un degré
d'engagement peut-être qui est différent
selon les époques et les gens oui alors
selon les époques je sais pas
l'élu en règle générale les hommes
politiques tous les femmes politiques
qui m'intéressait était vraiment engagée
oui bon ensuite y en a qui étaient
presque obsessionnelle et d'autres qui
étaient un peu plus désinvolte quand
même y en a qui faisait passer fois
qu'ils gardaient une place importante à
leur vie personnelle et d'autres pas du
tout oui parce qu'il ya des moines aussi
parmi les hommes ou les femmes
politiques je pense vraiment qassam atta
mills ce soir par exemple chez chirac
était un moine c'était un mois d'un peu
lubrique comme d'ailleurs au ballon
était beaucoup de moine mais enfin c'est
m il respirait la politique il est ne
quittez pas la politique
alors je sais bien qu'il avait des
lectures par ailleurs enfin la politique
ça devait occuper 99 % de son temps
ouais bon ben arfa s'est blessé tout
seul mais bon les grands étaient quand
même très engagé en politique même s'il
n'était pas exclusivement des politiques
il y en avait certains qui étaient en
vacances vous en avez croisé qui étaient
là mais bon à j'en ai croisé dont je me
suis dit que si c'était données de plus
de mal qu'ils avaient accordé plus de
temps à l'art politique oui il aurait
fait une autre carrière oui oui oui
c'est bien sûr est ce qu'on peut dire
que le contraire d' engager en politique
ces arrivistes
non parce que pour être arrivé s'il faut
être engagée simplement la différence
entre engagé état est arrivé c'est que
l'arriviste est engagée pour lui même
mais l'école engagé est engagée aussi
pour les autres
donc ça fait une grande différence qui
nous a le plus intrigué le est-ce qu'il
y en a qui vous ont étonné retourner
déçu ébloui jusqu'à ébloui
pendant ses deux premières années une
source a incontestablement par
mitterrand orange était très lié avec
lui tout en ayant des idées notamment
politiques économiques très différents
tous les dires qui se moque éperdument
de la politique économique et qui
considérait que t'es pas sérieux
mais les débats gaz et un mitterrand oui
mais il était engagé mais distant c'est
à dire que lui pour le coup se ménager
en permanence qui est très rare chez les
politiques le maroc où il se ménager en
permanence un espace de liberté
c'est quelqu'un qui s'autodéterminer
tout le temps il avait envie de s'en
aller trois heures ils sont allés trois
heures il
il faisait annuler ni chose il avait
envie de réfléchir de lire ou de faire
autre chose ou d'aller tout simplement
voir 3 bouquinistes de livres anciens
etc
non non c'était quelqu'un de totalement
libre alors comme personnage je dis pas
commode d'état comme homme d'état il
avait des qualités puis il avait
quelques défauts comme personnage c'est
de loin le plus passionnant que j'ai
connus de fram vraiment de la sécu
berthet justement oui puis il avait une
profondeur de culture il avait un regard
historique était très intéressant bon
nicolas sarkozy j'ai adoré son son
dynamisme et sa vitalité son énergie je
peux pas dire que j'étais d'accord avec
lui politiquement ça c'était autre chose
et puis j'étais conscient de ce que vous
dites là la forme ne me satisfaisait pas
d'autres justement vous avez une phrase
à ce propos que je vais je vais vous
citer parce que c'est difficile que vous
vous étiez vous même à partir de nicolas
sarkozy ça a été la fin de la
considération respectives la fin du
respect des deux côtés vous parlez des
journalistes et les politiques la fin de
la confiance et l'entrée dans un univers
médiatique en sauvage est donc cette
phrase elle est de vous à cause de quoi
à cause de sa personnalité
la personnalité aussi sa manière il faut
pas tout remettre sur lui mais disons
qu'il l'a incarnée mais c'est le moment
où la communication politique est
devenue complètement différente c'est à
la fois professionnaliser caricaturer et
lui il l'avait fait en 2007 une campagne
électorale éblouissante à l'américaine
c'était une campagne à l'américaine
complètement différente de tous les
autres c'est pas ça qui encourage c'est
le cas tout ce qui va avec
oui c'est qu'à partir du moment où
commence vraiment à professionnaliser
tout et avec les moyens matériels que
s'impliquent et c'est à partir de ce
moment là les les rapports deviennent
complètement différent alors en ce qui
concerne les journalistes et la question
de la considération qui est très
importante
disons que les rapports entre les
journalistes et les hommes politiques en
fait ont changé avec l'alternance et les
cohabitations oui
avant je le dis
son au début de la vème république
quand j'ai quand même vécu au début les
réacs ème république
les hommes politiques
regardez les journalistes dans le
meilleur des cas comme un proviseur
regard d'un élève dissipé bon
aujourd'hui je dirais pas que celle
inverse mais aujourd'hui les hommes
politiques sont tellement dépendants
sinon des journalistes du moins de
l'information ce qui est bien quand même
largement même ils sont tellement sous
pression ils ont tellement besoin d'être
en permanence mis en scène et c'est que
le rapport des forces est assez
largement inversée vous parlez de
l'emprise vous dites avancées le
politique avec l'oppression journalistes
et c'était scandaleux aujourd'hui c'est
le journaliste quel l'emprise sur le
politique et c'est navrant les est
dangereux mais qu'est ce que c'était
bien alors je me mets ça c'est normal
c'est normal c'est au 19e siècle et
rapports entre les politiques et les
journalistes c'était hystérie oui mais
quand je dis hystérique ça aller jusqu'à
se battre en duel et c'est au sens
propre un avec une épée à la main ou un
revolver a donc enfin pistolet les
banques c'est les rapports entre les
politiques et les journalistes ont
jamais été équilibré n'ont jamais été
vertueux n'ont jamais été recommandée à
blois
mais ils ont néanmoins complètement
changé et ils sont obligés de cohabiter
quoi qu'il en soit là a dit que c'est
l'actualité les chaînes d'actualité qui
ont la main sur les politiques on a
quand même le sentiment aussi que le
journaliste ait battu froid par par le
président de la république par exemple
beaucoup de mépris d'un monde aux jeux
les politiques n'ont pas grande
considération sur les journalistes en
particulier parce que les journalistes
parlent trop des personnes et pas assez
des dossiers assez des dossiers par
exemple ceux qui sont au pouvoir quels
qu'ils soient
oui ça j'ai vu ça plus de 50 ans ceux
qui sont au pouvoir considèrent toujours
que les journalistes
alors en fait quand ils disent ça il
s'agit surtout de journalistes
politiques évidemment c est ce que un
journaliste économique ça connaît son
dossier parce que ça n'existe que comme
ça pour les journalistes politiques
c'est vrai qu'ils attachent tellement
d'importance aux personnes aux arrières
pensées à la psychologie petites phrases
écologie sans arrêt et que sur le
contenu c'est pas toujours du même
niveau vous l'avez jamais fait vous
psychologiser quelqu'un or quand je fais
un portrait oui quand j'écris important
qu'est ce que là c'est inévitable
autrement autres mangent beaucoup les
gens sur leurs compétences lit ce qui
est aussi une façon d'évaluer la mienne
qu'il n'est pas infaillible mais qui est
laborieuse ok sur le fond le terrain on
va dire on a les politiques qu'on mérite
dit le dicton vous êtes d'accord avec ça
collectivement oui comme société oui une
société a les politiques qui mérite mais
qu'elle mérite et c'est de ce point de
vue assez inquiétant aujourd'hui
oui vous avez d'ailleurs vu était cette
défiance qui est plus la défiance
aujourd'hui en gaïa d'abord le d'abord
il ya le mépris des citoyens oui et pour
les politiques et pour les journalistes
qui sont d'ailleurs mis
même si dans le même sac à main cela
monnaie mondiale qui faisait pas
toujours leur métier donc on peut le
comprendre
non parce que deux entrées entre être
insuffisant et avoir des défauts et être
méprisé il ya une grande différence
ferme là là c'est de l'ordre du rocher
oui bon il ya un rejet des politiques ya
un rejet justifier ce rejet des
politiques vous qui les connaissaient
très bien ce qui est vrai et qu'il très
compliqué que les gens je pense commence
à mesurer mais ça n'est d'ailleurs pas
sans inconvénient c'est que la marge
réelle dont disposent les politiques au
pouvoir est de plus en plus faible donc
qu'ils ont de moins en moins la
possibilité d'améliorer les choses comme
en règle générale ils en ont envie
quand ils sont au pouvoir ils ont envie
d'améliorer les choses et ils en ont de
moins en moins la possibilité dont qui
déçoivent donc ils sont rejetés et donc
depuis
en réalité depuis le 2ème septennat de
françois mitterrand tous les ai toutes
les élections présidentielles ont été d
élection de rejet du hunan et ses soeurs
et pas de projet du successeur et donc
ça c'est déjà une forme de d'éloignement
entre les français ceux qui les
gouvernent et on a bien vu avec les
gilet jaune à quel point il y avait même
une haine de ceux qui incarnent le
pouvoir oui et alors moi j'étais frappé
parce que j'ai toujours mes petits
travaux parce que je suis un dut en
bonne élève l'âme laborieux je regardais
ce qu était l'attitude des français
vis-à-vis de la société dans les années
70 les français étaient optimistes
européen
trouvant que globalement la société
s'améliorait bien et je dis pas qu'ils
étaient libéraux mais enfin il avait une
idée assez tolérante des rapports entre
l'économique et le politique
aujourd'hui il son pessimisme il rejette
les politiques et ne croit plus à
l'europe
il croit et il déteste la société dans
laquelle on vit
la grande majorité des français alors
ils savent pas ce qu'ils voudraient à la
place mais qui pourrait faire rêver
alors parce que tout à des zones la
réponse à ça c'est que du coup ils sont
affolés de nous
t puisque comme il rejette ils veulent
quelque chose qu'ils croient être
différent vous vous avez rencontré
mendès-france qui est le mendès france
pour pour la france ou pour écrire ça
aujourd'hui a pas d'équivalent n'y a pas
d'équivalent mais aujourd'hui vous
n'avez plus en plus de la politique
comme la défense ou ou comme raymond
barre ou comme delors capable de dire je
suis dans le camp d'en face le je ne
voterai pas pour vous mais je reconnais
que telle loi que vous nous proposez ou
telle décision que vous venez de prendre
la bonne
oui aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus mais ça
fait 30 ans que ça n'existe plus les
danois que vous avez vu un politique
faire vraiment quelque chose c'était
quoi annonce a impacté le pape a essayé
de faire acte est vraiment bon bah si
impacté impact est vraiment bon si je
voulais développer ça je pourrais
prendre l'exemple de la réforme des
retraites ce qui est sarah un impact et
c'est une réforme de société ce qui lui
arrivera autrement quand il ya eu la
crise la grande crise économique de 2008
mais sarkozy à jouer un vrai rôle pour
empêcher une catastrophe à bon compte
françois mitterrand est arrivé au
pouvoir la première année et à
transformer la france en pays de cocagne
tout ce dont les gens rêver il le
donnait la retraite
plus plus tôt le smic + eau etc etc
bon alors on peut pas dire qu'elle ait
pas d'impact on peut se dire que c'était
pas raisonnable mais on ne peut pas
gagner mais pas d'appareil giscard
pendant ses deux premières années sur
l'évolution de la société des moeurs de
la place des femmes des jeunes et ses
impacts ils avaient vraiment changé
beaucoup de choses et bomba emmanuel
macron il essaie de changer
alors est ce qu'il y arrivera ça je ne
fais pas de pronostics vous connaissez
les seuils
vous connaissez très bien bien très bien
peu emmanuel macron je connais pas bien
mieux pas bizarre ne rien y connaître
mieux
non pas forcément non je m'intéresse
beaucoup je regarde beaucoup joué par
d'ailleurs à l'ipp sûr et je suis pas
sûr que en tout cas j'ai pas du tout je
suis pas du tout comme ceux que je
respecte mais qui quand il faut un livre
sur un président veulent absolument leur
encontre et 30 fois tu t'es pas
nécessaire non pour moi pas qu'c'est pas
nécessaire c'est que c'est dangereux
c'est dangereux n'est pas un livre de
fausses confidences sur un livre de bon
essayer de comprendre alors c est rigolo
parce que vous gardez vos distances
alors que vous êtes celui à qui on a
reproché ses amitiés que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure avec françois
mitterrand avec lionel jospin c'est quoi
la bonne distance entre les politiques
et les gens n'aiment et c'est entre le
journaliste et lui même en fait c'est ça
qui détermine ce tout dépend enfin la
question est de savoir si on a un une
partialité ou pas assumer ou ou assumer
ou camouflé donc partiel ou pas et deux
si on a une dépendance ou alors on veut
pas développer à l'infini mon cas mais
moi j'ai toujours pensé que je n'avais
pas de dépendance vis-à-vis des
politiques
et que je leur parlais les questions ne
pas parler d'égal à égal mais je vais en
parler comme je voulais où l'on parlait
en tout cas par exemple françois
mitterrand
je le voyais jeu pour combien de fois
j'ai vu en tout cas je crois que je
calcule une fois à peu près 120 x wing
ou c'est vous le voyez dans des
situations privé dans la danse et cirque
ou recevoir toutes les surcoûts mais on
n'était pas du tout d'accord
je veux dire par là politique économique
sociale ben non seulement n'était pas
d'accord mais un an après qu'il soit
qu'il est élu président j'ai publié un
livre qui s'appelle la république de
monsieur mitterrand dans laquelle je
disais cette politique économique n'a
aucune chance
c'était l'idée du livre de réussir bon
donc je peux pas dire que j'étais
complaisant avec lui n'étaient pas
complaisant mais c'est vrai que ça
énervait beaucoup de gens parce que
quand quelqu'un d'intéressé ben je le
voyais wicked jean jacques bourdin qui
revendique de ne pas fréquenter les
politiques et vous elle mieux informés
alors mon côté je pense qu'il est bien
informé quand je regarde ces interviews
donc il est bien informé donc ça veut
dire qu'il travaille ses dossiers je
vous ai dit que c'est important que ça
se produit oui ensuite chacun a son mode
de vie
puis vous avez des éléments qui jouent
toujours ce qui est la même formation
dont je prends l'exemple de raymond
barre vraiment bas on était prof c'était
un des professeurs les plus connus à
sciences po moi je n'étais pas des plus
connus mais enfin j'étais quand même
jamais ma petite notoriété ça me donnait
de sa part d'abord une forme de
considération particulière qui
quelquefois était gênant il lui est
arrivé dans des débats à l'heure de
vérité de m'appeler mon cher collègue ce
qui n'était pas absolument ce que je
l'aurais souhaité mais oui parce que ici
ils savaient que quand il m'expliquer où
quand un de ses collaborateurs
m'expliquer quelque chose à priori
j'avais une chance de le comprendre
qu'ils avaient intérêt à me l'expliquer
et donc bien sûr que j'ai angers ça m'a
donné des coups d'avancé
on n'a jamais été tenté de les rejoindre
n'a jamais que tu en revanche on me l'a
proposé au moins
demi douzaine de fois dans tous les
partis non à tous les partis disons dans
des partis différents en tout cas à
droite va donc oui enfin qui était de
chaque coup de chaque côté de la
frontière c'est ça c'est droite et
gauche se met en place et oui on l'a on
me l'a proposé
oui mais je n'ai jamais hésité un quart
de seconde vraiment un quart de ce
congrès
vous êtes beaucoup d'observateurs et
puis sont tous je pense que je suis fait
pour ça et que je suis pas du tout fait
en plus je pense que non non je ne serai
pas je serai pas un homme politique
convenable c'est pas convenable mais
c'est à dire que l'idée d'être à la
disposition de tout le monde tout le
temps de voir voir tout le monde tout le
temps et ses terrasses non pas du tout
l'idée de pouvoir être mobilisé tout le
temps de jamais pouvoir lire à fond
travailler dans son bureau sans être
dérangé et tout ça est impossible et
surtout l'idée de la discipline bon ça
veut dire si on est en politique quand
on doit être en dessous est solidaire on
donc on doit être disciplinée donc on
doit pas on renonce à la moitié de sa
liberté c'est vous qui dites ça alors
que will êtes vous avez la réputation
d'être le moine les journalistes c'était
oui mais jeu discipliné vis-à-vis de
moi-même et pas vis-à-vis des autres
c'est différent vous vous autorisez
c'est vous qui vous parler avoue même
discipline les autres disciplines et
vous n'avez toujours pas d'ordinateur
dont vous dictez toujours vos papiers je
les écris à la main et mais j'ose écrire
au stylo
oui ensuite je les dis que tu voulais
dictée toujours oui c'est étonnant 50
oui c'est étonnant c'est comme ça et ça
va ça raconte quoi de vous raconte que
je n'ai aucun esprit pratique
oui parce que la stricte vérité oui vous
disais mon papier à votre femme
quand ils sont publiés oui mais pas vain
avant le grand départ son avis un nom si
je lui demande son avis mais après après
oui bien sûr je lui demande tout à fait
son avis c'est même la première personne
à qui je demande son avis mais après
tout je ramais après oui oui et parfois
elle vous dit me dis pas non elle me dit
pas ça mais il y en a qui l'intéressent
vraiment et d'autres qui l'intéressent -
et en a qui trouvent réussi
moi mais c'est vrai des papiers mais
comme c'est vrai des interviews à la
télévision comme c'est vrai des débats à
la télévision et là un jour je trouve
que j'étais intéressant à l'autre jour
elle m'a dit qu'elle avait déjà lu ça
dans un papier trois semaines avant
jusqu'à sûrement voix elle vous parle
d'elle parce que je pense que ça a été
j'ai eu le sentiment tout cas que vous
nous racontez vous dites souvent que ça
a été la rencontre la plus importante de
votre vie est-ce qu'elle a influencé
votre travail votre manière de le faire
est de ma manière pas du tout d'autant
plus qu'elle en est plutôt victime
mon travail est là beaucoup influencé en
me permettant de le faire à fond et de
le continuer tard puisqu'elle cas alors
que ben c'est forcément un peu à son
détriment dans ces cas là c'est au
détriment d'autres choses bon je ne peux
pas ne pas lire six heures par jour
donc ça veut dire qu'en vacances je suis
insupportable mais parce que je suis pas
disponible
donc c'est un énorme défaut mais j'en ai
d'autres vous avez trouvé dans ce métier
dans l'exercice que vous en avez fait
exactement ce que vous imaginiez je ne
peux pas dire ça parce que d'abord comme
je voulais dire une part de chance donc
je peux pas voilà c'est ce qui est
arrivé les quelques os x n'est pas
arrivé par mois mais pour moi c'est pas
pareil
bon ensuite parce que ce métier a
énormément changé depuis le début mai et
puis parce que les itinéraires ont été
assez comme je vous dis assez atypique
oui à un moment où quand même je faisais
à la fois la télévision la radio la
presse écrite la presse écrite
quotidienne la presse écrite et de
madère n'a presse écrite régionale bon
ce qui les a valu d'ailleurs décrit ce
qu'elles seront bien sûr c'est normal ça
qu'est ce que vous voulez
c'est logique de toute façon quand on
arrive va réussir quelque chose on
expliquait il à et d'ailleurs c'est
souhaitable mais mes succès et quelques
fois c'était justifié
j'en ai fait - après progressivement
puis toutes façons l'âge venant je me
réduit oui vous avez un regret quelque
chose que vous n'aurez pas fait que vous
vouliez faire
bon ben il ya des choses faciles du
genre de il ya des gens que j'aurais
rêvé d'interviewer et puis ça ne s'est
pas trouvée mais c'est pas en france ça
s'est produit c'est à l'étranger il ya
des personnages qui m'intéressait
beaucoup je n'ai pas eu l'occasion
d'être vu par exemple
oh ben si il y avait 1-1 des présidents
américains m'aurait beaucoup intéresser
bon ben c'est comme ça ça s'est pas fait
c'était lequel obama
cela dit je me serais probablement
trompé parce qu'il m'aurait séduit comme
il m'avait séduit en arrivant et ensuite
je me serais repentis comme j'ai été
reporté à la fin
bon mais enfin bref ça m'aurait je vais
pas raconter d'histoires ça devrait
énormément intéressé parce que je
trouvais d'un fois qu'il avait du charme
pic c'était une mécanique intellectuelle
vraiment intéressante
donc ça ça me rend intéressés et puis il
ya toujours des livres qu'on rêve
d'écrire et qu'on n'a pas écrit réécrit
une bonne vingtaine mais oui il
n'empêche qu'il ya toujours des choses
qu'on a envie de faire et puis mes mails
phoque quand je regarde les choses
globalement bombe h 30 j'ai beaucoup
travaillé mais sans doute trop que j'ai
et j'ai fait des choses très différentes
les unes des autres que j'ai été
critiqué mais bon c'est la vie
d'ailleurs si je n'avais rien fait je
n'aurais pas été critiqué et que
globalement je peux pas dire que j'ai un
regret majeur n'a donc si c'était à
refaire ça se passerait autrement ça se
passera mieux non mais différemment
sûrement serait en train de pianoter sur
un ordinateur
je saurai pas de quel côté on regarde
une caméra
il est probable que je serai beaucoup
moins cultivés mais que je serais
beaucoup plus efficace que voilà c'est
bien
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
c'était chouette toujours accompagne
vers celle-ci vos coups à l'abdomen
[Musique]
à